[Musique]
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors l'italie qui
assouplit ses mesures de restriction
mais c'est un assouplissement contre la
vie quand même des scientifiques votre
pays qui continuent d'enregistrer en
moyenne plus de 300 morts chaque jour
mario draghi de son côté parle de risque
calculé est ce que c'est un pari risqué
bonsoir effectivement les on nettoie sa
des réouvertures alors c'est une
situation de très compliquée très
délicate
il faut que les italiens saches que même
si on a plus de liberté même si on peut
retourner au restaurant même si on peut
retourner au cinéma il est à la
situation épidémique ne change pas donc
il faut toujours être alerte il faut
toujours prendre des mesures de
contention du virus entre entre les
personnes c'est vrai que avec le beau
temps les personnes se retrouvent quand
même dans les parcs
c'est faut faire attention de toute
façon le gouvernement est ce qu'il a
cédé à la pression des dirigeants la
pression si économique
oui c'est vrai que la situation est très
compliquée très grave ici les il ya
beaucoup de restaurants de magasins en
faillite on voit ça dans les rues de
milan moi j'habite à milan mais même
dans toutes les villes d'italie c'est la
même chose donc c'est vrai qu'il faut
retrouver un point de rencontre entre
les citoyens et les médecins et la santé
c'est vrai que ce n'est pas facile
5 2 millions d'italiens sont désormais
vaccinés 350 mille doses de vaccins
administrés chaque jour dans votre pays
depuis quelques jours d'ailleurs le
gouvernement a rendu la vaccination
obligatoire pour les soignants et les
pharmaciens est-ce que l'italie
peut compter sur cette campagne de
vaccination pour réussir santé
confinement moi je l'espère là c'est
vrai qu on a augmenté les doses de
vaccins administrés chaque jour on
procède assez efficacement
on compte de rejoindre les cinq cent
mille doses par jour c'est vrai que
c'est un des gros chiffres mais nous en
tant que médecin on s'implique dans ses
dents cela et on sait que les citoyens
aussi veulent se faire vacciner veut
sortir de cette situation donc on
l'espère que c'est là c'était assez
rapidement et comment se déroule
justement la campagne de vaccination est
ce qu il ya d une défiance vis-à-vis de
certains vaccins astrazeneca par exemple
ans comme c'est le cas chez nous en
france
malheureusement oui il ya quelques
préjugés par rapport à ce vaccin fait
des personnes qui ne veulent plus se
faire vacciner là qu'astrazeneca et
c'est vrai que les l'opinion publique a
est très influencée en affluence et
aussi parce qu'on l'entend on l'entend
aux noix aux infos bon en tant que
médecins et scientifiques
moi je me suis fait personnellement
vaccinés par 20 astrazeneca et je crois
dans la science et je sais qu'il ya les
risques ne sont pas plus forts que les
bénéfices donc j'espère que mes
concitoyens considèrent maxine de toute
façon et l'évolution des variants qu'est
ce que vous pouvez nous dire là-dessus
il ya une grosse inquiétude en ce moment
dans toute l'europe à cause de ce
nouveau variant le variant indien oui
c'est ça c'est vrai c'est vrai que voilà
le l'important c'est de procéder avec
les vaccinations de continuer et de
terminer enfin deux voilà deux d'avancé
avec les vaccinations dans le plus le
plus rapidement possible afin de éviter
la propagation de ces variants parce
qu'on sait que de toute façon la plupart
des vaccins protègent aussi des variants
et en nous vaccine ans en évitant la
propagation de ces variants on ne sait
on pourra aussi éviter la la la
propagation de nouvelles variantes qui
marie parce qu'elle m'est arrivé c'est
inévitable mais là encore il à la
question c'est de savoir si les vaccins
sont justement efficace face à ces
variants suffisamment efficace en tout
cas comment la population réagit en
italie alors je dois dire que les
italiens se font vacciner
surtout pour parce que on sait que même
si les vallées vaccin ne protège pas
afin ne limite pas les pontages donc on
peut être content âgées il diminue les
effets de la maladie donc c'est ça qui
est important c'est aussi d'éviter la
pression sur les hôpitaux donc temps que
les vaccins nous protège la maladie et
nous empêche de tomber malade et de
terminer de de finir en hospitalisation
dans des
pandore dans des soins intensifs c'est
ça l'important
s'agissant du variant indien il ya deux
cas recensés dans la région de venise
l'italie qui a fermé ses frontières avec
l'inde ça c'est une bonne décision selon
vous oui c'est vrai que la fermeture des
frontières et vite
le déplacement des personnes évitent la
propagation du virus
maintenant c'est vrai que voilà avec les
nouveaux variants il faut quand même
faire attention il faut quand même
maintenir les gestes barrière ça ne
change pas c'est toujours ce qu'on sait
ce qu'on fait depuis un an donc même
s'il ya de nouveaux variants il faut
continuer comme ça il faut continuer
avec les gestes barrières qu'on a
toujours fait merci beaucoup à vous
keneya genovesi je rappelle que vous
êtes médecin à milan merci à vous